the tale of viking warrior omleth's
revenge in the northmen has plenty of
twists and turns leading up to an epic
vengeance-filled climax the ending is
full of startling revelations but what
does it all mean to omelet's destiny
stay tuned because this is the ending of
the northmen explained
in the northmen audiences first meet
omleth as a young boy who idolizes his
father king alvin deal as well as the
kingdom he expects to inherit that of
course doesn't go according to plan
avondale's brother fuelner executes a
brutal plan that ends with the king's
death filner's brutal takeover of alvin
deal's kingdom sends young omleth into
exile and he does not emerge again until
years later now a man and a member of a
fearsome viking tribe for nearly the
entirety of the northmen omelette is
guided by three goals to avenge his
father save his mother gudrun and kill
fjornier to earn his vengeance
as an adult omleth stops at nothing to
achieve these goals as he murders his
way through filner's village in iceland
even when it grows clear that he may die
in the process the character embraces
the prospect of death from injury on the
battlefield as a personal victory that
will send him to valhalla or as it's
called in the film vol whole omleth runs
the risk of truly losing himself in the
process of achieving a goal he set for
himself as a child solely in the name of
revenge at one point omelette sets aside
a necklace given to him by his father so
he can disguise himself as a slave to
get closer to fjallnir and in that
moment he ceases to be himself instead
he becomes a tool of prophetic revenge
omelette's meetings with the cirrus and
other visions tell him that his children
with olga will rule the kingdom that
should have been omelets in the future
for almost his destiny lies on the
battlefield with his uncle shortly after
omlet's destiny has revealed him and he
remembers his vengeful oath the viking
warrior learns that his uncle has fled
to iceland this flight happens because
after deposing alvin deal fionnier is
defeated by another ruler fleeing to the
small north atlantic island to start a
new life after an arduous journey omleth
finally arrives in iceland to exact his
revenge but the northman offers a messy
conclusion that sets it apart from other
vengeance sagas omleth doesn't really
have a kingdom to return to and to take
for his own once he's defeated his uncle
all that's left of fjallner's domain is
a small farming community to infiltrate
fjolner's village omleth brands himself
and travels as a slave across the ocean
once under the control of his uncle the
prince sees that fjolnier's home is just
a small village in iceland filner lives
there with gudrun and their son gunnar
filner's older son torrer and a small
grouping of villagers and their slaves
filner has already been humbled by
external forces by the time omlith
reaches him and aside from murdering
alvin deal he seems to be a capable
leader in fact when we meet him again
he's teaching gunar the importance of
doing physical labor alongside the rest
of the village it's a moment reminiscent
of young amla's experience with his
father when fjolnier and omelette
finally do battle in head-to-head combat
at the base of an active volcano known
as the gates of hell omelette finally
achieves his goal of killing his
traitorous uncle however considering the
state filner is already in by the time
omelette reaches him it's hard to say
how satisfying reaching this conclusion
of his journey actually is
robert eggers portrays amleth as a
single-minded protagonist he's driven
solely by his need to achieve vengeance
for his father's death and the film
rarely suggests that omelets will fail
at that goal your fake is sick and you
cannot escape it
as an adult the exiled prince is a
violent and fearsome combatant he even
kills a man larger than himself when he
is conscripted to play an early version
of the irish sport hurling when omelet
is captured by fjornier toward the end
of the second act of the film his
captivity is brief ravens release him
from his bonds suggesting his revenge
isn't just his goal but a true destiny
bestowed on him by the gods and
completing the gods mission omelette
ascends to valhalla signified by the
electrifying visions of a valkyrie
flying through the night sky omelette's
revenge plays out even as he learns that
the reality of his family's existence
was not what he once thought the film's
first act implies that fjomir keeps
gudrune against her will after alvin
diehl's death but in a surprise twist we
eventually learned that it was gudrun
herself who plotted to kill alvin deal
brought into his kingdom as a slave
khadrun was forced into marriage when
alvin deal took notice of her this
startling revelation makes one third of
omelet's vengeful mantra obsolete it
further emphasizes the ways in which the
northmen muddies the waters of a classic
revenge saga not only is amleth driven
by a single-minded drive to fulfill his
destiny but when he learns the truth he
realizes that he doesn't even have a
clear idea of who he is actually seeking
revenge on ultimately his own violent
destruction is the only way his story
can end
the northmen is the third outing from
robert eggers following two films that
won him immense critical acclaim while
the witch and the lighthouse were both
made on relatively modest budgets the
northmen and its roughly 90 million
dollar price tag represents a huge leap
forward for the filmmaker with the film
receiving its own glowing reviews from
critics does this mean we can expect
more big big-budget blockbusters in
egger's signature style in the future in
the lead-up to the film's release eggers
has been candid in interviews about the
difficulties he faced in making the
northmen despite the significant amount
of action in the movie eggers noted to
the new yorker that neither he nor
cinematographer jaren blaschke had never
shot a significant action scene before
the project furthermore eggers admitted
that his filming methods left little
extra footage to make any changes to the
film something he ended up doing after a
series of test screenings eggers opened
up to the guardian about modifying the
film after submitting it for test
screenings a process he had not
undergone on his first two films while
he clarified that the give and take with
the studio helped produce the most
entertaining version of the movie he
could make he also alluded to not
necessarily enjoying the process while
it sounds like eggers is happy with the
end result of the northmen he has also
said that he doesn't want to step away
from making smaller scale films he noted
that he has had meetings with larger
studios but that he doesn't feel his
skills as a filmmaker are useful for
franchise blockbuster filmmaking so we
may see another grand epic from eggers
down the line but don't expect to see
him helming a marvel cinematic universe
film anytime soon check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you